hey everybody hope everybody had a good
Memorial Day weekend oh no my graphics
are all messed up let's see if we can
fix them hate it when that ha there we
go they are back very nice hope
everybody had a good Memorial Day
weekend here in the United States we did
take the day off at the David Pakman
show since there's nothing to do we've
not really taken a day off all year and
we took yesterday off but we are back
and we've got a Kaylee maghen annie
press briefing happening potentially at
the top of the hour potentially three
hours from now who knows now let me
address something right away I promised
a man bun at the next stream and I had
every intention of doing so because
people signed up for memberships and I
only have rubber bands right now and my
girlfriend is working and I need to get
some kind of element from her so it's
gonna have to be like tomorrow or
something I just I just don't know where
these elements are kept for the hair so
it's happening it's happening and now my
hair is more than long enough at this
point but it just we couldn't do it
today and it will happen it will happen
excuse me we're looking at it as Donald
Trump would say very strongly during the
next period of time as Donald Trump
likes to say so expect it maybe on
tomorrow's stream I am going to get that
all sorted and taken care of for you
okay we have sadly a tragic number today
which is that the United States has now
officially reached 100,000 coronavirus
deaths and there's there's a lot that we
can say about this one thing we can say
is Donald Trump said when we had 15
cases that we would soon have zero right
so that is a context that must be
considered when we are evaluating these
numbers number two a new study from
Columbia University says that just a
coordinated stay at home two weeks
earlier could have saved about 60,000 of
these hundred thousand people who died
number three
understand that Donald Trump claims this
is a success Donald Trump claims that
thanks to him we
winning by only losing a hundred
thousand people I would expect Kaylee
maghen Annie to continue perpetuating
that during today's press briefing and
probably talking about tests as well so
that is where things are today now
tomorrow on the show I'm going to have a
detailed report about how this number is
likely to low there are conservatives
who are arguing that this number is is a
higher than reality because they will
say doctors are saying people who you
know we're in a car accident died of
kovat 19 it's [ __ ] okay
the truth is we know Florida is likely
under reporting coronavirus deaths
Georgia has now three times had to
correct quote errors that made it seem
as though the numbers were going down
even though numbers were going up and
they used those numbers that seem to be
pointed down to justify reopening 11
states were combining infection tests
and antibody tests and talking about
testing it it's crazy what's going on so
if this number is inaccurate and
certainly it is it's too low it's too
low not not not too high so that's that
globally we are now approaching six
million cases 350,000 deaths and nothing
particularly new to look at here I do
want to just very briefly look at the
tests per day guys we are still not
testing 500,000 people a day
it has been months we we are seeing more
tests okay part of the problem is that
some of these numbers again appear to
include antibody tests which is not what
this is supposed to be there were States
reporting antibody and infection tests
that may be reflected in these numbers
so these numbers are nowhere near where
they need to be they may include
antibody tests it's a mess it's a
complete and total mess and I mean okay
if these numbers were accurate then we
are only like three months late getting
to 500,000
which is just a stepping stone onto one
to two million a day which is where we
really need to be if these numbers
include antibody tests it's just [ __ ] I
mean this is it's worth nothing we have
no idea what's going on it's an absolute
disgrace complete and total utter
disgrace don't know what else to tell
you that that's where it is right now
okay we are I have a few other things to
get to I will remind you we are standing
by for Kayleigh mag and Inez press
briefing at the top of the hour a couple
of super chats that have come in so far
Walker Anderson says very respectable
performance on Rogen we disagree on a
lot but you make well-thought-out
persuasive arguments you represented the
left very well all right thank you yeah
I was on the Joe Rogan program on we
filmed that Thursday they published it
Friday his audience doesn't really like
me very much
and that's okay that's okay what I mean
that's you know this is that maybe it's
it's probably better that I am getting
in front of an audience that is
predisposed not to agree with me and I
invite you to go over and check out that
that appearance if you would like
incredible TV says just want to send
some love David appreciate what you're
doing I'm in a fortunate spot to still
be able to support your work take care
of yourself thank you nasty questions
says loved you on the Joe Rogan
experience I could tell you we're
excited to be talking to Joe but you
kept it together very articulate and
detailed in your explanations you are
two of my favorite people thanks from
Texas thank you and MS Smith says hi
Dave thanks for the clarity
I wonder if Megan Annie will go on about
Biden appearance in masks versus Trump's
golf trip well I can't imagine she'll
want to talk about that at all by the
way guys as soon as I saw Joe Biden
wearing a mask
I immediately thought what a weak betta
tool I could never vote for this guy
then I stopped being a complete idiot
and I realized Joe Biden is just doing
the right thing and it is urgent that we
remove Donald Trump cynical and Sami Act
says I don't get how they can defend
employer-provided insurance right now
14% are unemployed it hardly matters at
this point how much time how much ill
time we've accrued yeah I mean the the
employer connection is fraudulent
essentially it's it's a absolute
disaster okay what else did I have
there's a couple other things oh yeah so
listen so Trump golf this weekend and
you know he previously attacked Barack
Obama back in 2014 Trump tweeted can you
believe that with all of the problems
and difficulties facing the u.s.
President Obama spent the day playing
golf worse than Carter this was at the
time of the Ebola quote outbreak two
people died in the United States here's
Trump golfing as we Eclipse 100,000
deaths I'm gonna be totally transparent
I don't give a [ __ ] about his golfing in
the sense that if he were doing a good
job with coronavirus and he managed to
go in golf great great I don't care I
like for me I'm about work smarter not
work harder I'm about be efficient I'm
about get get your work done and then go
golf and that's great work-life balance
the problem is this guy does nothing and
he has failed Bigley on coronavirus so
the the golf is a representation of his
laziness and his hypocrisy and his
double standards it is not in and of
itself the problem you know remember he
said when he was running I probably
won't have time to even leave the White
House and he's golfing way more than
Obama ever did it's the hypocrisy it's
the fact that he's failing and golfing
if this guy was succeeding in golfing
great amazing we've got a guy who who's
just doing doing fantastic oh and and
he's still able to golf and he's solving
problems that's not what we have let me
say thank you and welcome to everybody
who's watching me on Twitch including
bolo who says with the with their twitch
Prime subscription loved your newest
conversation on Joe Rogan's podcast I
appreciate that you give your opinion
without coming off overbearing or is if
you have all the answers very
respectable thank you bolo I appreciate
that and of course I always appreciate
twitch supporters upper trend has also
subscribed with twitch prime just a
couple of seconds ago and I very much
appreciate that
well thanks for joining me I know I
haven't streamed since I think Thursday
so I had Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
no streams but plenty of YouTube clips
in case you were a confor some content
if you are watching on youtube remember
to hit the like and subscribe buttons
very important want to say thanks to
Yeol again now who is new member number
one today at join pakman.com very much
appreciate that
couple of other super chats that are
coming in Adam Bennett says seen the
model saying Trump will get 35% of the
popular vote I saw it
listen I don't doubt for a second that
right now Trump is losing badly to Biden
every poll Fox News poll every poll
model says it five months is a long time
and I just need people to understand we
can't assume anything this is how we
lose elections if the economy starts to
look better oh oh oh oh speaking of
which should I do this now yeah okay
I'll do I have a segment plan for this
week so listen you guys have to get
ready for what I'm going to call
trumpian fuzzy math we are starting to
see headlines like for example air
travel up 140 percent whoa whoa air
travels back No as many of you know with
percentages if you lose 96 percent of
air travel meaning you have 4% of air
travel remaining and then you gain a
hundred and thirty seven percent from
that point you're only back to nine
percent of where you were you're still
down 91 or 90 percent you are going to
be seeing this insane fuzzy math because
GDP is going to be a disaster for q2 we
won't get those final numbers till end
of beginning of August and device
they're now going to start to play games
with these look manufacturing is up 20%
well it was down 80% it's down 80%
employment is up X well hold on we but
we lost 37 40 45 50 million jobs
so I'm gonna prepare people with this by
talking about how this fuzzy math is
going to work and I think I think it'll
it'll be useful if not the most
titillating segment but that's probably
on tomorrow's show okay junior says I am
bone weary of the hatred the partisan
politics the deflections the lies the
blaming the egos the apathy and the
corruption on all sides David do we
still even live in a democracy anymore
in the in the most technical sense in
the most technical sense we still live
in a democracy
Kevin Macomber says thoughts on Biden's
black comments yeah so listen Biden's
comment was a gaffe there's no question
whatsoever
Biden gaffes all the time do I think
that the comment is evidence of Joe
Biden's inherent discriminatory
perspectives on black people no I don't
know I don't and you know for me in the
end Joe Biden was the vice president to
a much younger black man the first black
president of the United States half
black okay who cares in the United
States if you're half black you're black
there was every indication throughout
that entire presidency that Joe Biden
had the utmost respect for Barack Obama
and understood his role as the much
older white dude who works under Barack
Obama and he trusted Barack Obama and
that's it period I mean really what else
is there guys what else a dude this is
you know yeah Biden gaffed and it was a
stupid thing now if you said to me what
if Joe Biden had worded it differently
what if Joe Biden instead had said
listen given the disaster that
Republican politics have been for the
black and Hispanic and you know
non-white communities in the United
States for 30 years I can't understand
why anyone who cares about minority
issues regardless of your skin color
would consider voting to reelect Donald
Trump right I mean like there's a
way to communicate what Joe Biden was
essentially saying that wouldn't have
been a gaffe and I would have been right
there with him so you know he said that
he spoke in in I don't know what he said
in eloquently or he didn't say it in the
right way he regrets the comment
whatever come on guys come on if so and
by the way if you care about that and
that would influence you not to vote for
a candidate don't you have to weigh that
against the dozens of things that Donald
Trump has said like isn't it extremely
cynical and insincere to say whoa Biden
spoke in eloquently about how he
believes the interests of the black
community are aligned with the current
options of who to vote for and so I'm
not voting for him so instead I'm gonna
I'm gonna go vote for Trump right like
can you imagine something more
ridiculous okay let me say thank you to
Michelle deep Rose dent who is new
member number two today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate that
let's see Captain Crunch says we must
defeat the invisible scourge now watch
this Drive yes I get my thoughts exactly
my thoughts exactly Donna Williams says
were you appalled by the crowds
everywhere not wearing masks everywhere
this weekend thank you for all your hard
work yes I was I was and listen I don't
know that where this thing is gonna go
for a while there's no doubt about it
and people are crowding people are doing
all sorts of risky behavior you know I I
advocate just taking it slow here in
Massachusetts we're starting to open up
haircuts opened up yesterday now I think
increasingly the governor is poised I
would say to give the go-ahead to you
know if you can find a small social
group under 10 people of people who have
all been careful for the last two months
you may you know hang out with them in
social distance I by the way oh that
people might be interested in this I
visited some friends outdoors over the
weekend and I held their puppy look at
me
this was instantly my most popular
Instagram post ever ever ever ever
holding babies and puppies just does
really really well and
you would have known about this days ago
look at how far behind you are and by
the way people talking about my power
thighs a lot of half the comments are
about my thighs more than anything else
and calves you would have known about
this days ago if you followed me on
instagram at David Pakman but yes I held
a dog and you know it was it only weighs
9 pounds right now so it was it was a
beautiful beautiful experience what am I
talking about what is the message the
messages Instagram Instagram is the
message thanks to Margot Cabot for
subscribing for three months at tier 1
on Twitch very very much appreciate that
thanks to everybody who is watching on
twitch of course I care very much about
you guys nakute see I see the nonsense
you're spreading I care very very much
about twitch and appreciate everybody
who is who is supporting there we are we
are in from the standpoint of twitch we
are in a very solid position I guess I
would say okay other super chats coming
in let's see here
Marika says I'm sorry I bothered you in
vain because of yesterday's non show
Memorial Day dammit PS I have grown a
quarter inch tomato beat that okay thank
you Maria Lilith has upgraded her
membership to beta Keven Macomber says
Republicans are attacking Biden for
comments yeah I mean there of course
that doesn't tell us anything about the
comments bacon lover says what is your
take on the Fed propping up the markets
well listen if you look at the news and
you look at the markets something is out
of sync right we're approaching 20%
unemployment we are months from even an
emergency use vaccine that there is no
doubt that in a colloquial sense it
feels as though the markets are very
overvalued right now and it is of course
being propped up by the Fed now arguably
that's the point of the Fed getting
involved the Fed is sending money to
people people spend that money
businesses don't do as poorly their
share prices are held up that that's
that sort of the point the question is
is it artificial today the
markets have popped the Dow is up almost
700 right now yeah I've to me I don't
pretend to know where the markets are
going but these these numbers feel
artificially high they feel artificially
high to me let's see here you'll hear
says water the dog and give it lots of
Sun exactly Jakob Ratner says are you
worried about a constitutional crisis in
November no what I'm worried about
listen if Trump loses Trump is going to
leave if Trump loses Trump is going to
leave what I worry about is that Trump
will say it was rigged it will cause his
supporters to go out and do real-world
violence they have a lot of guns and
that there will be civil unrest as a
result and eventually Trump will leave I
don't think Trump will succeed at
actually staying in office if he loses
but I do worry not so much about a
constitutional crisis but about civil
unrest as a result of Trump claiming
that it was that it was rigged okay the
press briefing is going to start very
very soon I want to very briefly mention
our program continues to depend on the
support of viewers don't kid yourselves
the way this program is mostly funded is
people who sign up on my website at join
pakman.com now I'm gonna tell you a
secret
there's this coupon code 2020 now which
I've been promoting we did a one-day
Memorial Day special yesterday I am
going to give you the coupon code that
was released yesterday this coupon
expires at midnight tonight
ok the coupon code is Memorial 20 all
one word all lowercase Memorial to zero
Memorial to 0 you get a gigantic I mean
it's an embarrassing discount off of
website memberships you get the bonus
show you get all of that great stuff and
your name will pop up on a huge screen
in front of me and I will thank you and
we will fill the bar up hopefully with
that light blue color and we will get
225 website members and patrons people
were asking I mentioned in April and I'm
sorry if in March and April we saw 722
membership cancellations people have
been asking what is what is a May
looking like I've not added it up
recently but on the 15th
were down about 275 so much like
unemployment numbers the declines seem
to be slowing but they are adding up for
sure so really very much appreciate
everybody who's been supporting
everybody who signed up yesterday with
the Memorial Day special which you can
take advantage of that is Memorial
twenty20 the code works I already see we
have the perfunctory David the code
doesn't work the code works if you're
behind a VPN sometimes that will tweak
out when you try to enter a code but
it's certainly very very much works
extraordinarily strongly okay a couple
of other things that I wanted to go over
let's see if we can have I'll turn the
audio up just so we hear it when it
starts so we already did me holding a
puppy we did a hundred thousand deaths
we did testing we did golfing we did
hypocrisy
oh okay so here's Trump's statement
about churches being essential and
overriding governor's from last week
let's look at this just briefly I know
them well they love their congregations
they love their people they don't want
anything bad to happen to them or to
anybody else
the governor's need to do the right
thing and allow these very important
essential places of faith to open right
now for this weekend if they don't do it
I will override the governor's in
America we need more prayer not less
right thank you very much thank you so
listen there this is I have a big huge
segment on today's program about how
coronavirus for half the country almost
and for the administration has stopped
being a medical battle and it is a
culture war and Trump saying he will
override governor's and tell them you
must make churches essential he can't do
it he can't do it the tenth amendment
makes it very clear there are there are
two categories of things where states
can't decide category one is the
Constitution and Bill of Rights
specifically say the federal government
decides that's category one if it is
specifically enumerated as a power for
the federal government the federal
government has power over the states if
the Constitution or Bill of Rights say
that states cannot have power over
something right a negative claim states
are precluded from exercising power if
it doesn't fall under either of those
the states decide and that's the
situation
deciding what types of organizations are
essential is not restricted to the
federal government and states are not
blocked from it therefore Trump talks
about federalism he has no idea what it
is this is what it means read the Tenth
Amendment and it means that the power
rests with the states but it can't it
doesn't matter because Donald Trump is
waging this as a culture war like I said
and as a result just saying that he sees
churches as essential just saying he
will override governor's that's enough
right if you're an evangelical voter if
you vote based on religion you don't
care that Trump will never override
governors and you don't care that Trump
doesn't have the power to well all you
care about is Trump said it Trump said
church is essential Trump said he would
override governor's that's all that
matters and that is just another example
of how this is purely a culture war at
this point in time other countries are
fighting this for what it is which is a
global pandemic it's a medical incident
in the United States this administration
is fighting this as a cultural war and
it is sort of propped up on the urgency
of Donald Trump desperate to get himself
re-elected in November okay let me thank
a few people who are signing up on my
website I want to say thank you to
Michael row no who was new member number
three today
Andres Semin s'en is new member number
four today
Thank You Michele French has signed up
at join pakman.com and his new member
number five
Laurie Hamm is new member number six
Joleen Melnick is new member number
seven and Chris Dennehy hey Chris chris
is new member number six I'm sorry eight
today at join pakman.com very much
appreciated
okay other super chats that are coming
in let's see here hero she loves you
says hey guys who's which nickname for
Trump do you like better harbinger of
death is it harbinger or harbinger I
never remember that or tweety okay you
guys can you guys can debate that I want
to say thanks to KB twitch for
subscribing with twitch Prime as the
user name implies Tim video says craving
another debate between you and Jesse Lee
Peterson we all need a good laugh in
these dark times thanks for covering
these briefings David yeah I would love
to do that I mean just for the lulz as
the kids say
Michael Rowe nose has just signed up
keep up the good work yes Michael I just
saw your membership come in and I thank
you I love it also want to say thanks oh
boy the memberships are coming in fast
and furious Kathy Donlon is new member
number nine
Steve syren is new member number ten and
Charles drain Ville is new member number
eleven Oh Raymond Lopez how can I forget
Raymond as well Raymond Lopez new member
number twelve today we are so the last
Kayleigh press briefing that I covered
went 26 minutes they're often very very
short and it was scheduled for five
minutes ago for people asking she often
will start 10 15 20 30 40 minutes late
and it'll run somewhere between 20 and
25 minutes so that's what we're up
against and hopefully it will start
sooner than later because I've got a lot
of gardening to do you should see oh by
the way I'm not going to tell the story
now because we just filmed the bonus
show but I excuse me by the upcoming
language I have a story relating to
rabbits that I told on the bonus show
today I have a literal [ __ ] show going
on in my backyard right now the
situation in my backyard has gotten
extraordinarily ugly and if you sign up
for a membership the first thing I would
do is go and listen to today's bonus
show where I tell the entire story but
you you have no idea what I am dealing
with in my backyard
right now it's an absolute and total
fiasco okay thanks to you angel 10x who
subscribed on YouTube rent holder says
it simultaneously feels like Trump has
been president for three months and ten
years yes I know the feeling
in the same way that it simultaneously
feels like just recently we weren't in a
quarantine and yet it feels like we've
been in quarantine for a very very long
time
incredible TV says you're enlightened
centrist take on Rogen Rogen's program
is hilarious and accurate thank you also
as a black man myself as disgusted as I
am by Biden's comments I'm still voting
for him because he is still better
incredible thank you thank you for your
message I very very much appreciate it
let me see if I had anything else as we
wait here oh yeah oh so trump is a
calling Joe Scarborough a murderer on
Twitch this is crazy and I've got a
story about it on today's show so I
won't spend too much time on it you know
talking about Joe Joe Scarborough might
have killed a woman it's it's absolutely
bonkers also a bunch of people where is
this hold on oh I'm not finding it let
me see how I let's see Trump Memorial
Day balance a bunch of people are
questioning yeah okay here's the video a
lot of people are questioning Trump's
balance that he was really kind of like
shaky during this entire Memorial Day
thing and it is true that if you look at
him he's moving forward and back a lot
and it could be you know he has some
people say that the reason he stands
hinge forward is because he has lifts
that pushes heels up and they lean him
forward but he certainly seems unsteady
and at different points I mean listen I
don't know what's going on with the guy
I don't know if this is nothing I don't
know if Trump is very susceptible to
wind there was a four mile per hour wind
yesterday I don't know if Trump has an
inner ear problem sometimes balance
issues or early signs of dementia they
can be side effects from prescription
medications they can be you know he
could so there's speculation that Trump
is on uppers those make it very
difficult to stand still Trump could
have a tea
HD which makes it difficult to stand
still for long periods of time I have no
idea he certainly was going forward and
back and kind of like his body is just
try adjusting go over too much to one
side and momentum gets the best of him I
I don't know you know it's I don't know
that we'll ever really know what's going
on with Trump but yeah I mean he's like
a flag in the wind kind of moving back
and forth and there you see it again
just really kind of I mean he's you know
this isn't a tremor to be very clear
it's not a tremor it's that he seems to
just be doing these small adjustments to
stay on balance while he was at the
wreath there was also it was also
noticeable yeah when he had his hand up
oh he turned back okay so now maybe it
was like this area yeah a lot of shaking
his legs he's kind of like it's I don't
know guys I have no idea 12 12 or 13
people sent this to me yeah there it is
anyway make of it what you will
I don't know what to make of it but a
lot of a lot of you guys had asked me
about it so figured I would pull it up
um okay other members to thank here we
may be about to get into some
pronunciation problems okay Darryl
clothes is new member number 13 thanks
Darryl william crap
whoa that was weird what just happened
there that was really weird
I think I just did something that was
those odd I think we're back William
craft I was mentioning is new member
number 14 want to say thank you to
Hannah azzedine who is new member number
15
Cassie Abington is new member number 16
today
orange tabby cat lover is new member
number 17 oh it looks like we may be
getting close here
very good who else do we have
Kingsley mag POC is new member number 18
Patrick O'Neil is number 19 and Martin
O'Brien is number 20 okay we may not be
that close although when John Roberts
sits down usually it means we're pretty
close he doesn't like to sit around for
the nonsense also thanks to Cathy Donlan
who made a pledge on patreon but
everything counts today number 21 okay
other super chats coming in let's see
here Maddie ice PPD says quality of life
for vulnerable communities will be
categorically worse if Trump wins in
2020 Republicans already pivoting to
insidious budget cuts that will harm
millions of Americans never Biden equals
privilege Wow
green lover says word up brother keep up
the good work
we love you in the UK thank you Donna
Williams says Trump awarded Rush
Limbaugh the presidential freedom award
Biden is nothing like Trump yeah
certainly I mean this is not the most
important thing but Rush Limbaugh's not
getting a Presidential Medal of Freedom
under under a Biden administration but
not a very important issue just a signal
Kevin mccomber says what are your
thoughts on Tucker Carlson every once in
a while he says something that makes
sense overall pretty vile annamaria has
upgraded her membership to beta on
youtube Sankyo ship says thank you for
going on the Joe Rogan experience great
chat yes if you're just joining me I was
on the Joe Rogan experience on a Friday
and I would
love if all of you check it out and you
know vote your conscience on it I'm not
telling you whether the whether to like
or dislike it dislike it for all I care
but vote your conscience that's what I
care about Sabrina Zafar says hi David
loved your Joe Rogan episode however not
a fan of him calling your show homemade
yeah I know I mean literally right now
because of the virus we are shooting out
of my home but it was okay all right
here's Kaylee Maggie and Annie let's see
what she's got for us today hello
everyone I hope you all had an enjoyable
weekend I have some brief announcements
for you today just that now we have 760
sites in a retail locations in 45 states
plus the District of Columbia a CVS is
planning to open an additional 650 sites
these are encouraging numbers it's again
a testament to our private sector for
all that they've done in partnering with
the administration and helping to stop
the spread of the corona virus also
skilled nursing facilities there was an
announcement that I just want to
underscore that four point nine billion
in additional relief funds were
distributed to nursing homes and other
skilled nursing facilities and these
funds are provided under the cares Act
so just those two items for you this
morning and we'll go ahead and we'll
start with questions John China is
making more
sending more overtures that it will
crack down on Hongkong what's the
message from the administration to the
Chinese government about changing the
special status at one common yeah and I
know Jen I you also emailed a question
about this this morning so I went
directly to the president to get an
answer on this and he said to me that
he's displeased with China's efforts and
that it's hard to see how Hong Kong can
remain a financial hub if China takes
over so I have no further announcements
as to the precise action that the
president will be taking but he did want
me to share that with you this morning
this afternoon I should say yes no
probably I realize now we saw a lot of
images over at the Memorial Day weekend
of people gathering and large crowds not
maintaining social the students remember
that ISM after the lake of the ozarks in
Missouri was one example we saw all over
television news that the president many
concerns about those kinds of gatherings
we haven't heard any message from him
addressing
well the president as he's noted he
wants to see society reopen wants to see
the economy reopen but we do want to do
so safely and there are institutions
that have put into place these social
distancing measures and people are
making it cognizant a part of their
everyday lives for me for example I went
to Mass this weekend and people were
socially distant like they were washing
their hands there are ways to do this
and the president went underscore to
everyone that we should be taking into
account these measures so yes everyone
while you go out let's keep cognizant
the recommendations of the CDC because
those on a man are very important to
making sure that there is no spread of
the virus and I would just also note one
point I did have some updated numbers
for you on reopening and what we're
seeing across the country that I think
are important on that 42 states are now
under 10 percent in their positivity
rate for the virus mortality is now
equivalent to what we saw at the end of
March that's the lowest level in two
months so we are seeing these
encouraging signs as we start to reopen
[Music]
which seem to be criticizing Joe Biden
for wearing a mask
was that as a tension and if it was why
would you criticize that I think look
you know the president's excited to see
that Joe emerged from the basement it is
a bit peculiar though that in his
basement right next to his wife he's not
wearing a mask but he's wearing one on
what outdoors when he's so pointed
because because they live together what
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
noted himself he wore this mask and
privates on at the Ford facility and he
said he's open to it if the circumstance
mandates it the guy has to wear a mask
outside it's recommended but not
required so it's the personal choice of
the individual but it didn't strike him
as a very data-driven decision Aguilar
we're in a basket yes if we can just do
a little housekeeping personally no
Katie Miller Smith is back at work today
is the White House that way back at work
and as anybody else within the White
House complex tested positive for the
virus besides those two individuals and
we learned about a couple weeks ago so I
don't know about the valet I haven't
inquired about that no updates as to
who's tested positive or not that's not
something I regularly keep tabs on but
Katie Miller is back at work we're very
happy to see her recovered I spoke to
her yesterday I haven't seen her today
but she did have several negative test
results before she reinterred the
building and let us know if anybody else
people are worried about the president's
safety the vice president's can you let
us know that nobody else is talking
positive in the two-plus weeks that have
now passed since those cases I can
inquire about events people's personal
medical decisions I'm not entirely sure
that that would be given to me but if I
can the President and a tweet earlier
today so that he's made governor's look
very good by getting them what he said
was unlimited testing that's not true
you said that it's not even necessary so
why is the president saying
what he means by that is that the
governor has requested a specific amount
of testing to reopen and he indeed has
provided that that's testing you would
agree it is what they asked for in phase
one it's the full panoply of what every
governor asked for that was given to him
well I've given to them and it's 300 to
400 thousand tests per day that we're
doing that's a really good number I
talked to animals while before coming
out here and the metric that here to
believe the w-h-o I don't particularly
these days no one says a good barometer
of testing is 10 percent positivity or
under I'm an admiral Ross shared with me
that we're naturally at 7.5 percent so
we're in a pretty good spot Stephen
Miller back yes I just saw him on an
outer oval so he is back in at work take
some some time away from the White House
though for a while he did he did he self
quarantined with his wife but they're
both back at work and healthy and happy
and we're very happy to see them around
fine at the Pentagon the top watchdog
over at the Pentagon he submitted his
resignation today can you say if that
was encouraged did anyone ask him and
can you talk about the importance about
those internal watchdogs that are in our
governing agencies so we you said it was
Glenn fine that was that's the first
that I'm hearing about this but with
regard to the other IGS
I would note that the president's within
his authority she was legal an executive
authority to appoint new IGS and he said
I think last week at some point that
it's within the decision-making process
of each entity the State Department each
department whether to keep their IG or
not I mean I would note that President
Obama has a precedent of firing IGS as
well and there were in fact 47 IGS that
signed a letter claiming the Obama
administration hindered their efforts so
there this is not without precedent on
when it comes to AG's yes
president's position with the Republican
National Convention should go forward no
matter what no matter what the cogut
infection rate is by late August the
president wants to see the convention
take place on he's noted that and he
wants to have a cooperative governor and
making that pursuit happen
that being said of course we always
assess the facts on the ground at any
time but at this moment the president
wants to see this convention take place
and sees no reason not to as the nation
begins to reopen nificant spike in the
cases he would be open to the idea of a
virtual convention understanding that
there couldn't be a traditional
convention so I won't engage on a
hypothetical as to where the cases will
be but I would just note that we assess
the facts on a day-by-day basis and
currently we're coming down on and
that's really encouraging to see and
we're ready for the convention to take
place yes that'll be a real pertinency
the letter that husband widow were sent
to Jack Dorsey Twitter CEO saying that
his tweets were emotionally traumatic
for him and for his wife's family I
don't know if she's seen the letter but
I do know that our hearts are with
Laurie's family at this time the
president found in allegations the
president accusing somebody of possibly
murder the family is pleading with the
president to please stop unfounded
conspiracy theories why is he doing it
well you know I would note that the
president said this morning that this is
not an original Trump thought on and it
is not in fact 2003 on Don Imus his show
it was Don Imus and joe scarborough that
joked about killing an intern joked and
laughed about it so I that was I'm sure
pretty hurtful to Laura's family and Joe
Scarborough himself brought this up with
Don Imus and Joe Scarborough himself and
the United States and he's accusing
somebody of possibly work this is
different he's he's he's not a private
citizen mr. president yeah and Joe
Scarborough if we want to start talking
about false accusations maybe that's lie
to you we can go through about other
clubs mica certain time to you and
saying this morning as recently I
believe was this morning or yesterday
mica accused the president of being
responsible for a hundred thousand
deaths in this country those incredibly
irresponsible they've dragged his family
through the mud they've made false
accusations that I won't go through that
I would not say from this Burroughs
against the President of the United
States but they should be held to
account for their falsehoods Joe
Scarborough should be held to account
for saying people will die by taking
hydroxychloroquine many never mind the
millions of Americans from people across
the world who take it for rheumatory
arthritis and other reasons there are a
lot of false headlines like mica no
they're not false conspiracy theory the
Securities acts possible for murder I
would point you back to Joe Scarborough
who laughed and joked about this item on
Don Imus his show it's Joe Scarborough
that has to answer these questions
Stephen keep asking about it if I could
two questions some John Radcliffe was
sworn in as intelligence director today
because the president decided
what's next for Dalek equipment he
hasn't but brick Rennell is a very
valued member of this administration
he's done extraordinary work at odni he
has a great history we'll see where he
goes next but just know that Rick
Grinnell has done an excellent job in
opposition I expect that John Radcliffe
will honest he takes over biases reform
and obviously its vices something he
cares a lot of balance now but he told
me that he had left it up to the
Senators to figure out and you know it's
still ongoing this process the house has
to pass the legislation that the Senate
passed Senate Senators fried and killed
by just one vote to ban the word
elections internet records so I'm
wondering how the press if you could
describe a little more how the President
sees himself this this debate and
whether he might intervene at some point
going forward
yeah it's very personal to the president
when it comes with fight comes to FISA
this is an important tool in the
intelligence community he knows that but
he also knows that it was used and
abused and politicized the fact that you
had 29 members of the Obama
administration they're 29 individuals of
Intel community and women no I'm asking
dozens of times using these tools that
are so much power to spy on an American
citizen to listen to their phone calls
to unmask their names we have a fourth
amendment in this country it protects
the rights of Americans although those
rights were not protected when it came
to President Trump and his
administration and Michael Flynn whose
name was leaked in a criminal fashion to
the press this is Liezel was not used
appropriately on a steel dossier full of
lies that was quote salacious and
unverified in the words of Jim Mahoney
was used as the basic you know paese
worn and attested to as if it were
truthful in a reason to spy on Carter
page these tools were used in abuse the
Fourth Amendment rights of several
Americans were violated a political
campaign was vital on so any FISA
concerns the president has they're real
they're personal and they should be
considered as we move forward to
reauthorize this valuable tool
that affected Rick prunella's one of his
last official acts at the request of
Adam Schiff Declassified transcripts of
the phone calls between General Michael
Flynn and Sergei kiss Lea with President
Trump encouraged John Ratcliffe to
facilitate the release of this
transcript I haven't spoken to him on
that but this president has released not
the president rather but this president
has overseen an OD and I that has given
the American people a lot of information
that I think they're entitled to see and
one of the things the president has
asked for is where the 302s the
summaries of that interview with Michael
Flynn 300 choose so the American people
understand these are summaries when you
interview an individual and it's routine
that those 302s are given in short order
right right after the interview is done
it's when your memory is at its best but
in the case of Michael Flynn those 302s
were lost and in fact edited afterwards
by corrupt Peter struck at least the
page for us there's a lot of questions
and this president has encouraged
transparency on this issue and I think
it's a great thing the absence of the
302s would he encouraged the release of
the transcript so that the American
people can see exactly what transpired
during this drawing I haven't asked him
that I'd have to ask them that
particular question yes let me I'll let
me get a few people in the back so I
want to make sure equal-opportunity
question caller so yes oh we're about to
across the hundred
American she hasn't paid the milestone
what what does the White House view as
having by Election Day what does the
White House view as the number of
Americans where you can say we
successfully defeated this pandemic is
there a number yeah you know every loss
of life counts we say 100,000 but like
the president says you know one death is
something to be more in hundreds of a
the president takes this very seriously
it's why he lowered the flag to
half-staff for three days to remember
these men and women I think you know dr.
Burks said it best when she said that
and their estimates they had anywhere
between 1.5 and - 2.2 million bucks for
the u.s. nothing coming to the virus if
we didn't shut down the economy the
president made the very hard choice of
shutting down the economy you didn't do
it States did it ordinary number every
one death is too many we've never want
to see a single individual lose their
life but that being said to be under
significantly that high mark shows that
the President did everything in his
power and helped to make this number as
low as humanly possible go to the polls
in November
and they want to judge the president
when his response to this pandemic what
is the number of said Americans that
they should tolerate as happen and where
they can argue that yes he successfully
I think you know you're asking the wrong
question the right question is where did
we're doing data answered your question
once but if you ask you twice it doesn't
make it any better of a question so
respond in kind I've given you one
answer I'll continue to extrapolate
unknown it he always listened to the
science the president when dr. Fauci and
dr. Burke said you need to shut down the
economy that was hard for the president
you know in a typical year 120,000
people die of suicide and drug overdose
it's in a typical year and doctors have
said when you shut down an economy for
an extended period of time that number
gets greater people Japan suicides are
way down they're a litany of results
when you closed down in an economy but
closing down the economy for this amount
of time kept us far below to 2.2 million
numbers as we start to reopen we keep in
mind the people who are missing their
screening appointments the people who
are not who are succumbing to suicide
and drug overdose because of economic
hardship this president made the right
choice it was a delicate balance and he
did it exactly notice the president made
no choice
responsible states were already shut
down when Trump started talking about
masks and all this other stuff you need
Timothy clocks Otis wrote quote
conspiracy theorists including most
recently the President of the United
States continue to spread their vile and
misinformation on the platform
disparaging the memory of my wife what I
want the president give this widower
piece and stop tweeting about this
conspiracy theory involving his wife
what president I've already asked and
answered this question and our hearts
our hearts our voice our hearts were
with Laurie and I think the onus is on
Joe Scarborough to explain his
interaction with Don Imus his show
shanell the winner is how far how
willing are you able to go forward and
say that he lied to the FBI or
obstructed justice in the process of
discussing rush inclusion and the Trump
family
well not know you we now have new
information showing that that Obama
himself used foreign intelligence to ask
for have no surveillance on the fifth
and 26th floor of top extent was John
Brennan behind that to what extent can
you share with with us what you know
yeah Brennan of all of the ID I'll call
them bad actors because indeed they were
of the Obama administration John Brennan
probably has the most to answer because
it was John Brennan who sat before
Congress and said the steal dossier
this is all a completely fabricated
distraction from the fact that a hundred
thousand people have died the reporter
doesn't even know what question she's
asking this this is a fantasy world I
testified before a FISA Court for its
truthfulness to spy on on the Trump
campaign so John Brennan of all people
probably has more to answer I so to to
Samantha power I'm see right here her
you say someone has blood on their hands
here under oath that they in fact
spoke to foreign leaders and
representatives of foreign leaders
during their transition but yet somehow
during the Trump transition that was
uncalled for what has been done
all throughout history was uncalled for
and meriting on masking and meriting
cornering General Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn all of these people have
really legitimate class all these people
need to be punished like they can't be
allowed to get away with this everybody
who participated in this era needs to be
held accountable the g7 summit so the
area still has a very high number of
cases a prime minister trudeau spoke
yesterday with the Chancellor Merkel and
president Mac Hall is the president
still confident of being able to
organise the event in like three weeks
and be three weeks from now if we stick
to the date it's a really great question
and an important one because the g7 the
president wants to see this take place
as America real opens as we try to
approach a place of normalcy where
people go back to work where people do
recreational activities but socially
distance while they do it the president
thinks no greater example of reopening
ominous transition to greatness would be
the g7 and the g7 happening here and
happening probably more towards the end
of June
Robert O'Brien I believe it was was
asked about this this weekend and Robert
O'Brien said that he's getting a great
reception from world leaders who are
asked about coming we will protect world
leaders who come here just like we
protect people in the White House so we
want to see it happen we think it will
happen and so far foreign leaders are
very much on board with the idea last
week of June in here in this York and
David I don't know if it'll be the last
week of doom but towards the end of June
and the goal for is it is for it to be
here at the White House yep yes right so
after the lowering of the flags this
past
does the president have any other plans
in the works to to honor the victims of
the the sweet conspirators go ahead
sorry and a larger question is does he
see his role as murderin chief in some
way which would be the traditional role
of president yeah I think he takes that
responsibility very seriously yeah he
said that this is the hardest part of
his presidency going through this demek
my goodness so many times that he thinks
about many of his friends some of his
friends I should say who have perished
because of this disease it's real to him
it's personal to him it's why he says
you know one death is too many and he
thinks about it all of the time so he
does see his role as that comforting the
nation but reopening the country giving
the country hope at this time as we look
forward to going back to work and
resuming our lives although in a new
reality with new CDC guidelines I think
lowering the flags is a great example
and we have further announcement he
dedicated his two-putt second hole on
Saturday to the victims
as soon as Emily I think is how you
pronounce it the Florida family they
have asked the president that the
widower has asked president in that
letter to stop talking about this for
Twitter to take down those tweets I just
wanted to ask you is the president
asking for someone for law enforcement
to reopen this cold case is that Lisa
defending is gonna ask the DOJ to reopen
something what is he asking for when he
talks about the cold case yeah I don't
have any future announcements on the
president's action but I would just
refer everyone for those of you who
haven't heard it go back and listen to
the Don Imus sound bite it was very
callous it was very cruel I mean I think
laughing and joking about the death of
an intern is really uncalled for and
that's something we can all agree to
thank you all very much and there it is
ladies and gentlemen just bailing out
and as usual absolutely no substance
whatsoever what how long was that let's
see how long this one was it started
where were we just under 21 minutes I
guess we'll call it yeah 21 minutes 21
minutes today may be a new record in
terms of short very very very short and
this is the unparalleled transparency
that they claim they are presiding over
let me make sure everybody who signed up
gets a Thank You Anthony Fowler was
number 22 Milton C was number 23 Malta
Malta
Martinson was number 24 find that
difficult to say Steven Wilson is new
member number 25 25 right on the money
thanks to everybody who joined me check
out my appearance on the Joe Rogan
experience published on Friday and make
sure to LIKE subscribe and follow
depending on where you are watching I
will be back with you very very soon
you